whoopi goldberg's comments on the
holocaust landing her a two-week
suspension from the view despite
goldberg's written and televised apology
following the swift backlash abc news is
benching her and asking her to quote
take time to reflect and learn about the
impact of her comments co-host joy behar
briefly mentioned the suspension at the
start of today's show watch
good morning and welcome to the view you
all saw the news whoopi will be back
here in two weeks
okay
harris is this
accountability is this consequence and
is it enough
this is short-sightedness on the on the
part of abc news and and look i i know
kim godwin just from earlier in a career
and going to like you know work expos
national journalism work expos that sort
of thing so i don't know what she's like
as a boss at abc news but she is a
tremendous leader
and the fact that she didn't deal with
this on the day bef on the day it
happened
is a mess
like we saw whoopi goldberg on stephen
colbert before we heard from abc news
why is that happening
why doesn't the president of abc
get a word in before the talk show host
goes on another talk show
that that just doesn't seem like
leadership to me it seems like a big
mistake and it's problematic for the
show because now you're in two weeks
you're going to say that you you're
going to fix that inflicted root wound
and i don't say self-inflicted because
it was inflicted on anybody who was
watching who was hit by that garbage
because it wasn't true
what do you say to those people when you
want them to watch your program when she
comes back the anti-defamation league
the adl has said that they accept whoopi
goldberg's apology i don't know which
one they're specifically talking about
because she's apologized more than once
but she but she apologized then on the
show the next day how does she get back
on the show after the muff-up that she
had on stephen colbert i mean all of it
is lack of leadership we know who she is
because through the years she's shown us
she's shown us who she is we we had it
on you know a montage video yesterday
so now what does abc do now if the
ratings go down while she's off the show
they bring her back they hope for the
best if they go up do they try to bring
her back or ease her out out the back
door
kaylee yeah when canceled culture comes
for the cancelers um i don't believe in
cancelled culture i i really don't um
but you know what's ironic about this is
these ladies do believe in canceled
culture i just had to do a cursory
google of the times they've talked about
cancel culture when gone the wind was
the subject of cancellation and cops and
other shows and they had a guest host
say if you do something horrible
sometimes there's a comeuppance and then
sunny hostin who sits there every day
with whoopi goldberg said quote this is
a long time coming about cancel culture
generally it should have always been a
zero tolerance policy for racially
insensitive behavior at work it was only
megan mccain who said guys this is a
slippery slope maybe we should stand up
against cancel culture good for megan
mccain but interesting uh when the
cancel cultural cultures become the
subject of cancelled culture
ben
yeah it's a two-week vacation let's stop
calling a suspension it's a two-week
vacation and the media want to protect
her abc wanted to protect her health cbs
wanted to protect her and put her on
their show and she screwed up the
apology
multiple times this is no accountability
this is a vacation whoopi will be back
they protect their own at all costs it's
disgusting what she said i would argue
it's a fireable offense it's not an
opinion it is pure bigotry and racism
from whoopi goldberg and what she said
it's a fireable offense in my opinion
but this is not even i would say a slap
on the wrist it's a two-week vacation
that many americans wish they could have
right now
uh you know john pederetz wrote a really
interesting op-ed for the new york post
uh where he pointed out that whoopi
goldberg you know her her real name was
karen johnson he says drop the goldberg
name that you co-opted whoopi you don't
deserve it i went on brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now